in this video I'm going to work through
the exact same scenario that we saw in
the last video but it'll be a little bit
more mathy and the reason why I'm going
to make it a little bit more matte these
so that you see it's the same ideas it's
going to have a little bit more cryptic
notation but it allows us to generalize
the ideas that we saw in the last video
so let's just assume instead of saying
that the marginal propensity to consume
in our little island is 0.6 let's just
call it a general let's just say our
marginal propensity to consume is C and
what we want to do is we want to figure
out given some initial initial change in
expenditure and this guy's change in
expenditure will be this guy's change in
income what is going to how is that
going to end is that that cycles around
and round due to the multiplier effect
what is going to be the total change in
our GDP so this is what we care about we
care about we care about our total our
total change in GDP and the GDP Y could
be viewed as what expenditure or it
could be viewed as income depending on
how you think about things so let's say
this guy instead of saying that he's
going to spend all of a sudden $1000
let's just call his and his incremental
change in expenditure let's just call
that Delta Y nought and Delta just means
change in and Y we could view this as
aggregate expenditure and I'm putting
this little 0 here so this is our first
iteration that this is the first time
that we're doing this one of these
deltas and then as we go keep doing them
we're going to have y1 y2 y3 and so on
and so forth so if we think about the
total change in GDP you're definitely
going to have this in the last example
this was $1000 this guy's $1,000
expenditures disguised a thousand dollar
income so then you have Delta Y nought
but then we saw that this guy he has his
marginal propensity to consume is si so
he's going to spend of the income he
gets he's going to spend si times that
so he's now going to do Delta y1 this is
the next kind of incremental bump in our
GDP we're seeing and that's going to be
equal to C times what he just got and so
are now after one after doing the 0th
iteration in the first iteration our
total change is going to be is going to
be C actually let me write it this way
times Delta y1 and Delta y1
this is just the same thing as C times
Delta why not
so it's kind of fancy notation but
seeing something fairly basic the exact
same thing that we said in the last
video now this guy all of a sudden above
and beyond what he spent in that 0th
iteration he's now getting Delta y1 he
has a marginal propensity to consume
we're just assuming of C so now he's
going to spend C times that so he's now
going to make an expenditure of I'll do
this all just in the same color he's now
going to do Delta y2 which is equal to C
times Delta y1 and so now we have Delta
y2 this up this new incremental bump and
they're getting smaller and smaller and
smaller but we can go an infinite number
of times and just to remember what this
is Delta y2 is the same thing as C times
Delta y1 Delta y1 is the same thing as
as C times Delta Y naught and so this
thing right over here is the same this
whole thing can be written as C squared
times Delta Delta Y naught this right
over here is C times Delta Y naught C
times Delta iy naught and this of course
is equal to Plus this is just Delta Y
naught and we can just keep going if
this guy this guy will then get this
amount and he'll spend C times that to
the farmer and so if we had a y3 it
would just amount to C times this which
is B C to the third times Delta Y naught
and we could keep going on and on and on
an infinite number of time but each of
these terms are going to get smaller and
smaller because we're going to assume
we're going to assume in order for this
to actually work we're going to assume
that C is between 0 & 1 C is less than 1
obviously when someone gets new income
and thinking of the simple case
someone's not going to be able to spend
more their marginally marginal
propensity to consume we assume it's
going to they can't spend more than they
just got and in general they're not
going to spend the whole thing so we're
going to assume that it is less than 1
and so this is exactly the same idea
that we did in the last one but now it
is general and we can simplify this a
little bit mathematically so this is all
equal to our Delta Y or total bump in
GDP due to that initial due to that
initial spark and if we factor that
initial
mark out we have the Delta Y naught
Delta Y naught actually let me do that a
different color so the math becomes
clear we have the Delta Y naught Delta Y
naught Delta y naught Delta Y naught
when I say not I'm talking about that
zero subscript if we factor that out we
get our total bump in GDP our total bump
in whether you want to view this output
expenditure income is equal to we're
going to factor that out the Delta Y
naught times and then we're just left
with we are just left you factor for the
change in Y naught here you get one and
then over here plus C plus C squared
plus C to the third and you go on and on
and on and the last video I told you
that this right over here is going to
simplify to 1 minus 1 over 1 minus C so
this is equal to this part over here is
equal to 1 over 1 minus C now you might
have not been satisfied and since this
is a more mathy video it's a good place
to actually show you that it would sum
up to 1 1 over 1 minus C so not to do
introduce too many variables but let's
just call this thing X so let's just say
I say that X X is equal to this whole
thing right over here it's equal to 1
plus C plus C squared plus C to the
third so on and so forth now let's
imagine what we would get if we multiply
x times C so what happens if I multiply
it I'll do this in a different color
what happens if I multiply C times X
well then each of these terms I can
multiply by C so 1 times C is C C times
C is C squared C squared times C is C to
the third the C to the third times C is
C to the fourth so on and so forth now
what happens if I subtract this from
that if I subtract the left-hand sides I
get X minus C X so I get X minus C X on
the left hand side I'll do that in that
pink color - where did it go I actually
think I changed the color on my so I'll
just write X minus C X and that's going
to be equal to if you subtract this
stuff from that stuff over there
this you'll have a c-minus see they'll
cancel out let me do this in yellow C
squared minus C squared that'll cancel
out C the third minus is there that'll
cancel out so every term other than one
is going to cancel out everything is
going to cancel out you're just going to
be left with a 1 here which is a pretty
neat trick in my in my mind and then we
can factor out the X right over here so
you get x times 1 minus C is equal to 1
and then you divide both sides by 1
minus C you get X is equal to 1 over 1
minus C and X was exactly this thing
right over here so this thing is equal
to 1 over 1 minus C so this right here
we just showed you exactly what we were
kind of we we told you in the last video
that the total bump in GDP this right
over here you could view this as a total
bump in GDP is going to be equal to that
initial bump in GDP which we called
Delta Y naught that was that initial
spending that that farmer did for the
and the builders initial income that the
total bump is going to be equal to that
initial bump times this expression which
we view is the multiplier and this is e
this is the multiplier right here is a
function of the marginal propensity to
consume so this right over here this
right over here let me label it all
actually we just rewrite it so the total
bump the total bump in our aggregate
expenditure or output come or output or
income is going to be equal to the
initial bump the initial bump times the
multiplier which is ends up being a
function of our marginal propensity to
consume so this right over here is our
multiplier multiplier plier and this
right over here is you could view that
as our initial bump and just to make
sure that it works out from what we saw
in the last video in the last video our
marginal propensity to consume was 0.6
so 6 C was C was 0.6 and our initial
bump our initial expenditure was equal
to 1000 and if you put point 6 in here
you will get 2.5 and so you get the
exact same multiplier and you get the
exact same total bump in GDP as we got
in the last video at least now we have a
little general and you're a little bit
hopefully a little bit more comfortable
with some of this notation that I'm
using
and unfortunately you'll see different
notation in almost every economic
textbook I just want to make sure that
this makes reasonable sense to you